my feet are killing me whoa it I mean
this is just the beginning right now you
know this yeah I mean I'm a first-time
nominee and I have no idea what I'm
doing I'm so excited to be here but I'm
very nervous in a good way you have to
enjoy every moment of it I'm by so fast
I just want to enjoy it as it comes
because this is like as I look out I see
some of the people that I admire most
and to be nominated alongside them is
the greatest gift I could ask for my
note the people that are nominated this
year it's unbelievable today I'm just
like so excited to meet you too thank
you thank you and you dress he's so
beautiful me too he's a good egg and a
and he he just really loves a woman's
body he really makes it look it's best
he's be fine thank you so much i shaped
it for my show that i'm nominated for
and i'm really excited because it's
growing out and I'm really enjoying the
growing out process absolutely and I
love keeping it sure I've kind of like
Heba I think it looks very stunning
audrey hepburn thank you very much thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]